did you buy or sell crypto this year or
maybe use it to purchase something even
as small as a sandwich if so that
transaction might need to be counted on
your taxes
it's especially important to talk about
taxes during this 2022 tax filing season
because so many people
bought or sold crypto during 2021 for
the first time the number of crypto
owners worldwide nearly tripled in 2021
growing from 106 million in january to
295 million in december according to a
report by crypto.com for those crypto
newcomers wall street journal tax
columnist laura saunders has a warning
i think that the irs has a special focus
on crypto because they're uncomfortable
with it they see it as a kind of a
threat to the tax system they think it
may attract criminal activity money
laundering or tax evasion so the irs is
paying very special close attention to
cryptocurrency here are five things you
need to know about taxes for
cryptocurrencies
first how to report you'll see this
question on the form 1040 right below
your name be sure you answer it
accurately if you don't answer the
question or if you lie and they later
have a case against you involving crypto
it will probably be a lot easier for the
irs to win that case but once you check
the box how do you know how much you owe
to find out let's look at how the irs
defines the currency
since 2014 the internal revenue service
has classified cryptocurrencies as
property usually investment property
that means they're not like dollars or
euros they're much more like shares of
stock like apple or ibm shares and like
income on stocks and bonds the law has
different rules for short and long-term
gains on crypto
if you've held it for a year or less
it's a short-term capital gain or loss
if you've held it for longer than a year
it's a long-term capital gain or loss
and those gains if their long-term gains
can be taxed at much lower rates than
say wages so the top rate on wages might
be about 40 percent the top rate on the
long-term capital gain on cryptocurrency
would be 20
that's a big difference the good news is
that capital losses can be used to
offset the gains meaning you can pay
less in taxes for the money you gained
in crypto if you also lost money
investing in the currency
[Music]
but capital gains on an investment isn't
the only way people use crypto some are
using the currency to buy goods like
that sandwich or even a yacht if you're
holding your crypto in a taxable account
versus say a retirement account like an
ira and you use it to purchase something
then you have a taxable transaction this
isn't a new idea that's just as though
you were buying that item with shares of
stock say shares of apple stock and just
the way that if you
transferred the stock to someone you'd
have to tell the irs and have a loss or
gain the same thing is true with crypto
also similar to stocks the irs says
trading between two different entities
such as from apple stock to microsoft or
in crypto's case from bitcoin to
ethereum are taxable transfers
what we just discussed applies to buying
and selling cryptocurrency and other
tangible goods where it gets trickier is
if someone is paid for services in
crypto which happened on a big stage in
2021.
the mayors of both new york city and
miami tweeted their plans to accept at
least one paycheck in bitcoin plus more
businesses are offering pay in crypto to
attract younger workers
in that case it's compensation so you
owe income tax on it but you also owe
payroll taxes such as medicare taxes and
social security taxes after you pay
those taxes it becomes an investment but
if the crypto is a gift rather than a
payment for a service neither the giver
nor the recipient owes any income tax on
that transfer
but
when the
recipient ultimately sells the crypto
they have to use the giver's cost basis
to figure the capital gain or loss it's
not the value at the time the gift was
received it was the value when the giver
bought it and if that value goes up the
recipient would have to pay taxes on the
gain when they go to trade or sell so
keeping a clear record is key
many people have what they call hot and
cold wallets for security purposes but
this also helps organize records the
cold wall would be kind of like your
savings account you don't touch it the
hot wallet would be the one you're
trading from and so you could tell the
irs no don't you don't have to worry
about the cold wallet let's look at the
hot wallet this is the one i was working
with transferring crypto between these
two wallets is a non-taxable transaction
the irs's rules on cryptocurrency are
evolving as crypto itself evolves and
moves into the mainstream some digital
assets like nfts don't have official
guidance yet but many tax specialists
think they should be taxed like
collectibles such as art or antiques in
that case the top tax rate is 28 which
is higher than the top rate on
cryptocurrency trades
my advice would be
even if there aren't rules don't think
you can do whatever you want to do if
you don't report correctly the irs may
find out about it for instance
they've talked to judges and been
successful in getting customer records
from places like coinbase that they can
use to match against people's tax
returns and generate cases the tax
deadline for 2022 is april 18th for
further tax questions see the wall
street journal's 2022 tax guide
[Music]